A Day of Reckoning for a government
that's prided itself on modernizing
India's colonial era rail network
balasor became the site of the worst
rail accidents in the country last week
when three trains collided killing
nearly 300 people months earlier an
Auditor's report was submitted to
Parliament warning about rail safety
issues that report is only now coming to
light
the four-year study highlighted
shortfalls in inspections Staffing and a
lack of funding for renewing rail tracks
demand is increasing but capacity of our
network has not kept pace so there is
over utilization
massive congestion
and that congestion has lot of cascading
effects you know last Saturday prime
minister Narendra Modi was scheduled to
inaugurate a new train instead he was
visiting passengers in hospital who were
injured in the balasor crash
the government says it's improved the
safety of the train Network in recent
years
but the report says budgets to implement
safety measures have been reduced
an anti-collision system that causes
strains to break automatically is
operational only on two percent of
India's rail network and it hasn't been
installed on the Eastern rail route
where last week's accident happened
this accident shows that this government
is not running the railways efficiently
the accident didn't involve one but
three trains who is paying attention
critics also say rail has failed to keep
Pace with changes in the transport
industry
so the problem is
that because of these safety concerns
because of this congestion
Railway is not able to raise speed with
the result that we are losing market
share
an accident that claimed hundreds of
lives may be among issues voters will be
concerned about during general elections
next year
I have been waiting for the train for
the past hour it's late isn't it the
duty of our government ensure it arrives
on time and takes us to our destination
safely there is a need to upgrade
India's rail infrastructure but can
modernization outpace safety of the
billions that are being spent to make
the network better experts say
Investments are needed in technologies
that make our trains safer
umeshwar Eastern India
still ahead and I'll just eat it